we have a look at this next question you
didn't have to think of turn okay but
what does it B is the line y equals 12
extra speed taejin to y equal x cubed
now I'm talked before about the value of
trying to get a picture in your head
before you put pen to paper and start
doing an algebra okay so here's the
picture in my head right I didn't draw
this as you can see I literally I really
made it this the picture that was in my
head right what's going on here's y
equals x cubed right now what they're
asking you about is and I've given you
the language for this right y equals 12
x plus b is actually in where jamadar
gets a family of primitive it's a bunch
of lines that all differ by a constant
the beat is just some number i try to
take what values in business and
therefore when you have a look at this
12 that's very steep gradient okay for
instance that they'll create could be 12
over here right that would mean i get a
tangent line something like that okay
now there will be a be that accords with
that it'll be up here I guess somewhere
but that is not the only tangent line
that's in this family of primitives
that's off by a constant if that's 12 x
because x cubed is an odd function i
should be able to come over here and
find a way that's exactly parallel wow
that's not bad anyway and and therefore
also tangential to y equals x cubed okay
so therefore before I put any algebra on
the page I'm expecting two answers
because I look like I have two tangent
okay so then I crunched the numbers and
I see what happened I've got two
derivatives here you know you didn't
really need to work out
Limited buddy I just did it for
completeness sake and here's my argument
the lines are tangential they're tender
to each other when their derivatives a
they share the same gradient right in
other words that equals that bricks
squared equals 12 I go ahead and saw and
as I was expecting I have two answers
that correspond to two lines now I'm
still not out of the woods yet what do I
do with these two answers what am I just
solved for X mo I have solved for the X
values Marcus pay close attention I've
solved for the X values where this guy
and this guy are the same I think X
values in other words i have just found
where is see this y equals x cubed right
I found where is the great year equal to
12 and the answer is at x equals
negative 2 which is there and x equals 2
which known use your imagination ok so
at those two x values that's what my
that's all my equation to solve right
you see how important it is to put this
line of argument here right certain I
know when I get an answer at the end
what on earth is my answer me because
now I know where to put it right what am
I after I'd love to be on time right so
in order to get for example let's look
it's left hand line in order to find the
value for B of this line this is y
equals 12 x plus be right but it passes
through what is this point here it's not
just x equals minus 2 can you see my
argument right over here I've said why
cuz they be today however that this
because I know it has to be tangential
to the cubic curve right so the
coordinates here r minus 2 minus 8 which
means y equals 12 expert fee has to pass
through that point so I substituted and
I get it out you for B and then I
rehearse the process noticing that x
equals 2 that's the point over here
that's also attention to write and so
therefore I put this into a different
why it was 12 expecially because I'll
get a different be right so you can see
like if all you knew how to do is
differentiate say okay I get the extra
rat you didn't you didn't get there did
you because I thought what do I do with
my inside you see the difference between
like doing a process like a different
[ __ ] will be I can solve the equation
will be but now we're like you're okay
so there's a big conceptual leap in
these tiny little errors here like to
know I better get some coordinates
because how else am I going to work out
with bees okay so don't fret if you're
like I just didn't know where to go
there there's a there's a big challenge
in this question as simple as it sounds
okay so that's the way I thought through
the rest is a little more
straightforward at least we get to the
power matrix yeah
no i catched up there a couple of
property so number one what is the
definition of a tangent a colloquial
definition which comes from circles not
from curves our colloquial definition is
intersex once because sure enough on a
circle that's what it will do okay
however it doesn't take that much
imagination to realize if I give you
like a pie graph like this okay and I
say what is the tangent to the curve at
this point it's a stationary point okay
tell me what you know about this engine
if it's a stationary point it must be
horizontal right clearly among about
that's terrible sighs clearly it must be
horizontal okay well if it's horizontal
you better bet you money it's going to
hit the graph another time okay so
therefore you see hitting the graph once
is actually not the definition of
materials the definition of attention is
it shares the same gradient at the point
of contact so therefore that horizontal
might I just drew is tangent to the
curve it's tareq here it's obviously not
tangent there but I'm not interesting
there i'm interested in here right so
it's a lot about do i hit once or twice
it's about do I share the same gradient
that's what's really going on which is
why I differentiate